la scène sous surveillance les péniches
se sont déjà organisés pour faire face à
d'éventuels débordements
c'est le cas de clément chaumette
vigilants mais pas inquiets pour le
monde jean crû de moyenne ampleur j'ai
envie de dire on a vécu bien pire en
janvier 2018 où l'eau était à peu près à
melgven au dessus par rapport à ce qu'on
vit aujourd'hui savoir que la scène est
un fleuve de plaine donc c'est ça se
remplit comme une grosse baignoire c'est
pas du tout comme on peut voir
actuellement dans le dans le sud ouest
de la france où c'est plutôt des fleuves
où des torrents de montagne qui déverse
énormément d'embâcles parmi les
principaux enjeux en temps de crue
l'amarrage contrairement à la situation
dans paris sur le bras de marly les
péniches peuvent être maintenus à
distance des quais peu importe la crue
on a la chance d'avoir des systèmes
d'amarrage qui sont assez performants de
pouvoir remonter soit sûr est quoi ce
soit sur duc d'albe dons qui sont des
gros poteaux qui permettent de retenir
le bateau et l'empêchait de dévier vers
le quai donc ça c'est une très bonne
solution pour maintenir le bateau en
place bien anticipé c'est l'une des
raisons d'exister de la bn association
des bateaux du bras de paul mara lee
elle permet par exemple aux habitants du
fleuve d'entretenir un lien avec la
commune
l'idée en fait c'est de communiquer très
rapidement entre la mairie et le et le
bureau de la bm des informations sur des
éléments de sécurité et une vigilance
une vigilance et une intervention plus
rapide et anticiper les bateliers plus
aguerris peuvent aussi conseiller aider
les moins expérimentés en cas de
problème on a créé des groupes de
référents qui sont des binômes qui vont
surveiller et qui vont collecter
l'information et descend de
l'information sur six bateaux et qui
permet une communication très rapide
entre les référents et le bureau de la
bm c'est une quarantaine de bateaux
stationnés dans les environs qui
partagent leur expérience du fleuve
via cette association ils font face
ensemble à cette situation à risque